it's silky it's rich indulgent this
chocolatey dessert has the perfect
balance of texture and flavors this is
our recipe for the perfect chocolate
tart
when developing this recipe we had a big
debate here about whether to do a
vanilla or a chocolate crust so of
course we tested both and ultimately
even surprisingly we found the chocolate
crust to be dry and brittle and a little
bit bitter while the vanilla was much
more tender and balanced so for this we
are team vanilla we're going to start by
making a basic short dough which always
has some kind of fat flour and water
we're using a food processor just
because it's a lot easier but you can
also do this by hand first we will
combine flour and our secret ingredient
powdered sugar powdered sugar is great
because it dissolves quickly and
contains corn starch corn starch helps
prevent gluten from developing which
will give us a really nice tender crust
and now add a pinch of salt i'm gonna
pulse this a few times and once it's all
incorporated we'll add our fat we tested
both with butter and shortening and
found that while both made great looking
crust the crust with the shortening
leaves a waxy mouth feel so for this
butter is just better so go ahead and
add in some chilled butter a few clumps
at a time it's got to be chilled because
we don't want it to fully incorporate we
are looking for a wet sandy texture like
this we'll leave that for a second and
in a separate bowl combine one egg yolk
vanilla and water this yolk is going to
help bind the dough and add another
layer of richness now that it's all
ready we'll drizzle it into the food
processor and pulse just until the dough
starts to come together we want to avoid
over mixing our crust so it's nice and
tender we'll wrap it in plastic and let
it chill for at least one hour to let
the gluten relax if we don't chill our
dough our butter will melt and be very
difficult to roll out and it falls apart
just like this it's terrible and we
don't want that so trust us just chill
your dough when the dough has firmed up
a bit a little trick we like to do is
place the dough between two sheets of
parchment and this way you don't have to
use more flour which will make your
dough tougher and it's less mess it's a
win-win we also like to rotate the dough
by 90 degrees every few rolls this helps
make sure we get an even thickness next
we'll transfer the dough into a tart pan
a little trick to help you do this is
wrap the dough around your rolling pin
and gently unroll it over your pan make
sure to press the dough gently into the
pan and then use your rolling pin to
remove any extra dough and make it flush
with the pan this dough is very
forgiving so if you have any extra feel
free to use that to do some patchwork
just like i'm doing right here you can
always use the back of a knife to cut it
to get a more precise edge next we'll
take a fork to prick holes on the bottom
of this dough which is called docking we
need to do this because we're going to
blind bake this crust which just means
we're going to bake this without the
filling these holes will allow steam to
escape which will help the dough from
puffing out since there's no filling to
keep it down after docking we'll freeze
this crust for 20 minutes to help it
firm up okay this crust is almost ready
to go last thing we like to do is add a
parchment paper a little trick i like to
do is crumble the parchment in my hands
that way it's easy to work with and then
we'll add pie weights this will also
keep the dough from puffing up and
baking unevenly if you don't have pie
weights feel free to use uncooked rice
or beans now we're ready to partially
bake this crust we'll first bake it at
425 degrees with the pie weights for 15
minutes then remove the parchment and
the pie weights decrease the oven
temperature to 350 and bake it for an
additional 15 minutes once it's done
transfer it to a wire rack and let it
cool while that cools it's time to make
our favorite part the chocolate filling
first thing we need to do is choose our
chocolate milk chocolate is sweet and
has a less intense chocolate flavor
while unsweetened chocolate can be too
bitter and a little bit overwhelming at
times so we landed in the middle which
is semi-sweet or bittersweet for this
recipe we are going with bittersweet
bittersweet chocolate is the perfect
balance it has the intensity of dark
chocolate with a little bit of sweetness
and next we'll chop up our chocolate and
if you can splurge and get more of a
high quality bar we recommend it since
this is the star ingredient we'll set
that aside and in a saucepan we'll heat
heavy cream and salt once it starts to
simmer we'll take it off the heat and
add in our chocolate we like to use a
spatula to make sure all the chocolate
is submerged under the cream we'll cover
this for five minutes to let it melt and
then stir until it's smooth we don't
want any clumps we want it silky smooth
just like this
in another bowl whisk together two eggs
and vanilla and then slowly add a little
bit of our chocolate mixture this is
called tempering it brings up the
temperature of the eggs without cooking
them this way you don't end up with
scrambled eggs in your filling now that
your eggs are up to temp add the rest of
your chocolate mixture and whisk to
combine but if you get any egg bits
don't worry we're gonna put this through
a strainer to make sure it's super
smooth then we'll pour this into our
cool tart shell look at that chocolate
it looks so smooth we like to use an
offset spatula to smooth out the top to
make sure it's even and we'll give it a
little bit of a shake before it goes in
the oven we'll bake this for 25 to 30
minutes we'll know it's done when the
filling is set and the surface is glossy
once it's done we'll place it on a wire
rack and let it cool we could stop here
but we're tasty so we're gonna add a
cocoa mirror glaze on top mirror glazes
could be intimidating but the one we're
gonna show you is foolproof first we'll
pick our cocoa powder we have three
types to choose from natural which has
an intense chocolate flavor dutch
process which is darker in appearance
and a little less bitter than natural
and onyx which is very dark and close to
the flavor of an oreo we chose natural
because we like the strong chocolate
flavor now we can start making the glaze
in a small bowl we'll combine gelatin
sheets with ice water and let that bloom
for five minutes
while that blooms in a small pot we'll
combine sugar and water and bring that
to boil once the sugar has dissolved
remove the pot from the heat and sift in
your cocoa powder sifting breaks up any
lumps that way we get a super smooth
glaze again we're looking for that silky
texture then stir until it's combined
then we'll slowly whisk in some hot
heavy cream we want to do this slowly
because we want to avoid adding any air
bubbles take your time and be gentle
we'll remove the gelatin sheets from the
water and wring them out make sure to
wring it out very well because you don't
want to add any more liquid to your
glaze we'll add our gelatin into the
cocoa mixture and stir until it's fully
dissolved
this next part is very important we need
to let the glaze cool until it reaches
90 degrees fahrenheit and if we wait too
long this mirror glaze will set and be
very hard to pour now that everything's
cooled it's time for the magic to happen
we'll put this through a strainer we're
going to pour this glaze on our tart and
again we're going to use an offset
spatula to help us spread it evenly
across the top we want it shiny and
smooth it's looking good we've done all
the work and now comes the hard part we
have to wait we have to let our tart
chill in the fridge for at least one
hour that way our glaze sets we know
that wasn't easy but we're done all
that's left to do is sprinkle a generous
amount of sea salt on top and serve
perfectly baked crust a silky smooth
chocolate middle and a mirror glaze can
we just appreciate all these beautiful
layers we'll top it with a dollop of
whipped cream
looks great let's eat we hope we've tart
you some new things today if you love
this recipe you can find it and many
more on tasty.go oh yes
[Music]
you